hmm welcome to this video playing we
must afford stuff never played him Anton
demchenko okay very high rated I don't
know this guy I heard this name but
there's so many GMS from the from the
let's say former Soviet Union Russia
Ukraine and so on you simply cannot know
them all okay is playing this super
aggressive line against my Kings inion
with 92 to be honest um this is tricky
because I know it only up to this point
where black takes and after that i have
what my own which is it sounds maybe a
bit crazy its move 18 but this is some
ah you should know it a bit deeper with
white yeah he's dashing out moves and
I'm not quite sure how it works here b6
g 3 this is this is a very dangerous
line for for both sides quite obviously
so damn do I let him check here for King
h1 and he's got each form h3 is very
often leading to sacrifices there yeah
and this is a theoretical position it's
it simply I should not think he I should
know what's happening and not knowing it
is a recipe for disaster actually ok so
after going to play this now and see
what he does with it it might lose it
directly didn't like Lewis directly ok
97 ok for Queen edge for hmm yeah I see
what he's getting edge
what a moon that's terrible 97 yeah this
is what happens if you don't know your
stuff I mean okay it was a blunder I
could have seen the move that's already
open it's already over him 97 yeah I did
not really think about retreating if I
take on c7 is going to play Queen edge
form and then he's reading made and my
bishop is hanging and i made it as well
it's not just not just a piece and if I
go Bishop before I which I have to do I
mean in a way but my mom told us now he
can play Queen age for I have to play 83
and next he can sacrifice on age three
hits over whatever that's an
embarrassing game now with this line is
this line is very tricky i play this 92
m now a little bit in blitz and I'm
always fearing that that they play this
stuff which is some yeah maybe not
objectively that great but as you see it
is very very dangerous ah so what what
what is happening here is there some way
to defend the problem is yeah that he's
going to take on age three do I have
some way to cover maybe I can cover on
the second rank in some way like a
Bishop d3 Bishop here takes Queen takes
look a to this kind of this kind of
thing I don't have the time to take on
c7 or stuff like that maybe maybe let's
do that take stinks so look a to now
so his threat is maybe just g2 can I
have somehow play so that i can take it
will be different it will be difficult
g2 on a book move Queen h1 I came
I'm young
yeah I don't know this is um I don't see
a move really check to defend and I'm
fit two and a half minutes down I came
so i'm not sure i mean at least i have
some active pieces on the queenside but
i'm probably just getting checkmated
somehow bishop f8 looks looks very
strong actually yeah okay I have to take
at least then we should be a rook g7 I
can I can capture but it still has the
threat there and I really don't have
have anything against that route g7
check yeah not just a terrible terrible
game yeah like this is this is something
if you don't know it in detail you're
going to get annihilated maybe this is
somehow somehow k of you if you are a
combo so but um I have my doubts about
that another computer is actually giving
like a straight win here yeah it is the
critical moment is exactly exactly here
this is this is probably still a
theoretical position and this is this is
probably probably just not working at
all yeah yeah as I said I mean I was
just I did not know what to do and it's
very very very sharp I just play to move
them yeah maybe I should play like
something like that or so I don't know I
really don't know what's what the what
the correct move is I think up to this
point it is some it is a known line we
should f eight or so
I really don't know after that is some
and probably am probably toast queen
here h3 and Knight f6 mm that's that's
just that's simple and good I don't know
I mean Bishop d3 is probably the only
move that candle prolongs the preceding
otherwise you just take h3 and it's it's
even simpler so this yeah I now I mean
this is g2s the big threat g2 queen edge
1 I have no move let's say he can what
can you waken can play g2 sure it's just
not working at all yeah this is just
completely winning check yeah and
probably if you give it to the combat
will show some kind of checkmate yeah a
disaster this line is some is very
dangerous especially in blitz chess
because whites King is under such
pressure the objective evaluation in
tournament shares of this line is a bit
it's a bit a bit dubious and nakamura
played it a couple of times with success
but it is very dangerous also for the
black player it's his burning his
bridges quite clearly but it's difficult
to play especially with this limited
time situation in blitz as you see and i
will say it was wiped out really quickly
okay well thanks for watching